i like my lone time as well and i feel i
feel like any healthy relationship you
have space to be have your alone time
but if you're feeling lonely you just
you're there's just someone there also
another thing is that uh the chores are
now like i have i'm in charge of all the
chores and i'm just like what is this
like this is going to sound a bit
misogynistic right but like
in in my in my household i'm in charge
of the washing up okay and sydney is in
charge of uh of the uh
of the laundry right right and so i was
just used to only doing the washing up
and having the woman doing the laundry
right
why did you have to say it like that i
just wanted to sound as misogynistic i
just want to sound as misogynistic as i
can because now i am there's no one to
do the laundry and i'm just like woman
where is my laundry done and i just
realized i have to do it myself now
i just like to imagine like i just like
slowly enter god's house from across the
house i just hear woman
i need a fresh pair of underwear you
really got done dirty because laundry is
like the easiest of the house yeah i'm
the one that does laundry in our house
yeah i think washing up the dishes is
far more painful i hate washing up the
dishes and what did you why did you
agree to that because i also hate doing
the laundry as well i just need to know
i like the laundry room
i mean like now that we've bought like a
washing machine with a built-in dryer
all i have to do is just like [ __ ]
take it out and fold it up but i like
the process of folding up washing i
don't know why i hate that it's just
it's it's meditative it's so unoptimized
i just i just like because the thing is
the thing about the laundry room
the thing about the laundry is that like
at least with washing up it's just a one
activity thing you get over with with
laundry you have to put it in and then
you have to remember that you put the
laundry in and sometimes i'm such a
forgetful [ __ ] that like you forget
hours after you afterwards that you had
laundry in the laundry machine yeah and
then you you take it out and it's
[ __ ] stinks yeah because you left it
in there for so long it's like wet so
then you have to re-laundry your [ __ ]
laundry
sounds like are you probably that is a
me problem god i hate the laundry
machines often have this very loud thing
called a beeping yeah it goes
when it's done yeah but sometimes you
just do you might have heard it on your
microphone some kind of same thing
sometimes you're just doing [ __ ]
sometimes you're just like oh let me let
me just finish up this piece of work and
then i'll do the laundry and then you
just forget that you hear that again
that sounds like a you problem like
because i have because if i'm doing work
and then i hear from my laundry machine
going dude i'm like all right time to do
the [ __ ] thing
i don't know how hard it is not that
difficult yeah also i don't have to
worry about dishes anymore because we
have a dishwasher so i wish i wish i
discovering civilization for the first
time yeah i mean like this is dishes i
was used to doing but like with laundry
is this how like is this how like men
felt in the 60s you know like
we're gonna get cancelled for this
episode
i'm not saying [ __ ] bro
cancel for this episode
because in our house i have to do the
the laundry and the dishes because
that's the one show that aki hates doing
so she does like the vacuuming and like
the cleaning up and stuff like that
because i i [ __ ] hate vacuuming the
house but uh i also hate vacuums imagine
doing all of it yourself yeah exactly
wow well i had to do that when i was
living on my own
but like now it's like
but now i feel bad because
my two chores which is the laundry and
the dishes i just let the machine do it
so i literally just like press a button
i'm like done
and it's great i wish i wish that was me
yeah i have to wash my dishes by hand
and my laundry doesn't have a dryer as
well dude i'm telling you man like when
you're when you like the dryers and
laundry machines i feel like they ruin
the clothes i don't like the dryer
either really i also hate having to put
out the laundry to dry yeah i hate
having to put out the laundry because
there's something good about an
old-fashioned natural drive it just kind
of gets to me it does it does but the
problem with that is that you are at the
mercy of the weather yeah right because
like what are you meant to do in the
wintertime hanging inside right the best
the best well i just hanging outside
we're going about what in the rain the
rain it's not permanently raining in the
winter yeah but what if you have laundry
that just finished and it starts raining
yeah oh it's unfortunate but you can
just hang it up somewhere else yeah
inside yeah so basically what i just
[ __ ] said that like you can do it
outside it's not a big deal you know no
it is a big deal because it's going to
get dirty again from the ring no that's
all right you could wash it again it's
even more clean see that's that's what
someone living on their own would say
yeah i know right
i would have said the same thing if i
was living alone because it's like oh
it's my clothes [ __ ] it who cares
but you know i have to take care of
another person's clothes and she doesn't
quite like that
does aki get like no you have to do it
this way oh no it's more so it's not so
much archie's preference it's also just
[ __ ] common sense don't try and don't
dry washing in the rain
out when it's raining because sometimes
you put it out then it starts raining
you forget that it's raining so you
didn't notice right away and it's a
little wet you're like i have to do it
again yeah yeah at that point that's
just annoying right because then you
just
if i feel like leaving out in the rain i
have to rewatch it yeah because i'm
butter
that washes out the good stuff about the
uh laundry right i'm simply one man i
cannot conquer nature i've accepted that
right so that's why i bought a washing
machine that has a really good dryer
you're trying to play god no no no no no
no no because
here's the here's the thing right here's
the thing because
if if you dry your clothes in the dryer
then you're going to need to eye in your
shirts right yeah i i feel i feel like
if it's like naturally dried sometimes
if you get if you get out just fresh out
of the washing you're like you're like
uh what's
whip
yeah i was trying to think of the
english word because i just needed a
thai word for it
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] whip the clothes
whip it yeah and it dries naturally you
just get the creases out and it's like
it's like a nice sometimes a lot of
times unless you're wearing like a
really expensive shirt or something that
needs to be ironed like most of the time
for like a natural t-shirt
um you get you get the creases out so
that's why i've always hated actually
having to use the dryer right
well i get that but there's also like uh
we use like these like kind of drying
sheets that you like throw into the
washing machine after it's done that
creates less creases in the clothes
it's like a thing apparently i didn't
know aki found on amazon and i was like
japan's [ __ ] game changer like this
that sometimes works sometimes doesn't
yeah
yeah put this in your fridge it'll make
it smell like oranges and then it like
smells like my last washing machine
supposedly had a dryer inside of it and
i spent it for like three hours and i
was like oh cool it's just a little less
damp than it was before japan is
fantastic the king is selling you [ __ ]
that you think you need that you don't
actually need it doesn't work
i just remember um so do you guys have
an issue of you like you're [ __ ]
trash
really really [ __ ] stinking in the
summer yeah like no
but i do i remember when i go to your
house your trash for some reason always
smells dreadful i don't know why because
doesn't smell that bad like the
burnables sometimes yeah cause like we
don't cook often right so sometimes it's
just we just we have we have like a
little trash there but especially in the
summer sometimes it just like [ __ ]
decomposes yeah yeah in the summer all
right and [ __ ] long are you leaving
this there yeah do you not throw it out
every week uh no well there's your
problem what that's why you're not
throwing it out every week oh because it
doesn't get full every week yeah it
doesn't matter like you should throw it
out how do you
as a couple get not get it full every
week i get it full every week yeah i get
it
yeah every week yeah i get i get a house
full every week
we sometimes have to go through like two
bags we have to go through like two bags
of burnables a week like i don't know we
finish off foods we i finish my food too
what you're trying to say
how are you feeling what are you what
does it feel for sometimes shot on
amazon comes in the box it's burnable
stuff you know and whatever like that's
cardboard no no no no like sometimes
they get material that's like not the
polystyrene and it's not bubble wrap
it's like the [ __ ] that's burnable yeah
and then like if you you know for
example like if you get uber eats for
example right yeah and like i get a lot
of ubereats yeah like the boxes and
stuff like that the food scraps that's
all burnable oh i feel very you wash the
boxes do you not wash wash your hands on
the box that was up material i did not
wash the box i just throw it all in the
bowl wow wow joey wait so what is what
is your stinky why does your stick give
you water
no no no because i don't push the box in
the burnables the burner balls is purely
just food waste well that's why it
stinks
and also you know like if you have like
um
certain materials if it gets oily or if
it gets stuck yeah
it's
yeah wait wait so so when you order a
pizza do you wash the pizza box when
it's done um like i i it goes on with
the cardboard like no
no that's not you're supposed to put in
the burnables dude
please stop greasing it no because most
of the time if it comes in like a
plastic tray or plastic whatever yeah uh
you can just wash it and then put it in
put it in the plastic
yeah so no no no about either the
plastic shell plus yeah plastic see a
lot of the food trays aren't like
plastic they're not plastic anymore
they're like cardboard
most of it most of it is plastic most
like most of everything i get is plastic
most of the stuff i could start
referencing so like what happens right
is uh is unfortunately most of my burner
balls like pretty much nine percent of
my burnables is like pure food waste
yeah and that just we don't have a lot
of food waste right right so it just
ends up that a lot of food like just
accumulates not a lot of food like a
little bit of food accumulates there and
because it's this in the summer it just
decomposes so quickly that's all the
more reason to take it out every week
even if it's not full i have like a
small bag that's attached to like the
kitchen counter yeah and because i go
through so much tea and tea decomposes
very fast yeah that's where all the tea
and all the small bits of food that i
don't eat right right so that it's a
tiny plastic bag that i can tie up and
take out every week but
it doesn't smell yeah i think i think
it's not actually just the food it's
just because it's so humid as well that
just like you should definitely get like
the humidity like condenses inside the
bag so you like it it ends up that you
have like the garbage water in
at the bottom yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah should definitely get through you
can throw out tiny bags you know that's
loud huh you can it doesn't have to be
big bags of trash yeah you can throw a
little you can throw a little like
combini bag levels of trash sometimes
you just forget like
that sounds like a you probably just
feel like consulting people on their
recycling no i mean what i was going to
say was so so obviously the trash ended
up smelling and at least like sometimes
they throw it up throw it out every week
in the summer but it's sometimes still
just smelled right i really like smelly
trash when i open the trash yeah yeah so
we had well in that in in my case if it
like if it you know i open up the trash
and it like really stinks like that
decomposing smell yeah i just double bag
it
so like i close up the first bag i get a
second bag and i wrap that up again and
then i only really do that if it's
written
yeah because what we did was we there
was like this there was this device from
uh daiso right i think it's by so or
like amazon already red flags
there was this device from begone that
uh was basically like like you know you
know that thing you put on the toilet to
make it smell nice when you whenever you
fly yeah yeah it was like the equivalent
of that but you put it on the bottom
of the lid of the garbage yeah yeah yeah
right yeah and completely solved the
issue
our
our bin smelled like great it smelled it
smelled fresh bran is the only country
on earth that gives a [ __ ] what is yeah
yeah [ __ ] smells like it it smelled
fresh and i was like great this is this
is a [ __ ] amazing device oh my god
this has just saved me this has made my
kitchen like actually pleasant to be in
yeah until until about like a month in
when we needed to uh take out the trash
and uh we noticed that what there were a
lot of flies like i don't know how the
flies where the flies came from you
never know where the [ __ ] is that i i
didn't know where the flies were yeah
you had a lot of flies i remember yeah
and i was like where where these fl
where are these flies coming from and
how
how why are they gathering all around
the bin because this never happened
before right and so um and so sydney
sydney opens the opens the lid and
there's there's like a few
we can see like literally like a few fly
eggs on the lid on the lid cover and i
was like what the [ __ ] how did this get
here and then
and then i i had to wash it right
obviously because sydney was sitting he
was scared of us i had to wash it and
then
and then i was like okay i gotta take
off the nice smelling thing take it off
and okay so that it's like it's like a
rectangle it's like a rectangle patch
and i took off the rectangle patch
and the entire patch was filled with
eggs i had like an entire patch of fly
eggs that were just covered because of
this one patch so this this nice
smelling patch this nice stunning
smelling patch
this nice smelling patch had just
attracted all the [ __ ] flies in the
vicinity i have no idea i have no
[ __ ] idea dinosaur you got to do
something about that [ __ ] and like i i
had to [ __ ] quarantine the place my
god
like the thing with the thing was like i
would throw the trash can out yeah the
thing was like [ __ ] chernobyl like i
had to let's like quiet to quarantine
the entire kitchen
that's so disgusting
yeah
yeah dude like i don't know what it is
like it doesn't matter if you have like
the cleanest kitchen in the world i
don't know where the [ __ ] these flies
are coming from they're just like it's
like it's like a re like the kitchen is
a respawn point for some of these
[ __ ] flies like they just appear out
of thin air it's like i am here now time
to terrorize yeah this is like you know
you know in like a jinjito manga when
you turn the panel and you see like the
monster that was it when i like shredded
off that [ __ ] patch shut the [ __ ] up
throw up please it's like a page turn
jump scare
stop